In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 9th, on which we commemorate.
The synaxes of righteous Joachim and Anna, ancestors of the Lord.
On the 9th of the month we celebrate the synaxes of the righteous ancestors of God, Joachim
and Anna.
It is as mediators of our salvation through the Mother of God who was born of them, that
we honor the righteous Joachim and Anna on this day, not as as customary in the feasts
of saints, the memory of their departure from this life.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on
us and save us.